how's it goin everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays my segment where you will
submit your theories I choose five to go
over each week you all vote on which one
was your favorite of the week and then
at the end of the month you all vote on
which one you think should win the
overall month and prize right now the
monthly prize is two imax tickets so you
can go see spider-man far from home in
IMAX or go see Avengers in game again in
IMAX tomorrow I'll post the video on
which you can vote for who you think
should win last month's Theory Thursday
sorry the video took so long to get out
but I'll post it tomorrow and you can
vote on who you think should be the
winner if you would like to submit your
own theory for a chance to end up in an
episode you can find that email to send
it to and the instructions and the
description down below
also if you're a fan of other movies
besides Marvel you can check out my
other channel cosmic culture where I
post news and theories about DC Star
Wars Star Trek and other sci-fi and
fantasy movies and shows I'll put the
link to that channel up above and in the
description down below alright
let's dive into some theories our first
one comes from Aaron Cardona who has a
theory about venom beam in spider-man 3
Aaron says what if Tom Hardy's venom is
already in the MCU and what if he wasn't
from a different universe in the
multiverse but from the same universe
here's how venom could be introduced
into the MCU in venom to Eddie Brock
accepts an interview sending him to New
York where he runs into spider-man then
he has given another interview but this
time it is on spider-man and he grows
curious about spider-man leanin venom to
tempt him to figure out who spider-man
really is Peter figures out what venom
is trying to do and stops him but in
doing so Eddie gets fired and sent back
to San Francisco while Peter is fighting
the villains of spider-man 3 Eddie is
left without a job but he's also
embarrassed because the news and the
media are spreading stories about him
being fired at the end of the movie it
shows what has happened to Eddie after
being fired consumed by anger with the
help from venom Eddie decides to get
revenge on spider-man setting him up as
a villain of the MCU and spider-man so a
couple of weeks ago there was talk about
Deadpool and venom entering the MCU via
spider-man 3
but Roger Wardell tweeted that Sony
actually wants venom in spider-man 3 and
I think this would certainly be a way to
introduce venom because
you want a classic venom spider-man
story we don't want venom and spider-man
to be friends we want to see them fight
each other sure eventually they can
become friends but what we want to see
is venom vs. spider-man at first and
spider-man being the reason that Eddie
Brock is fired and humiliated would
certainly make him want to seek revenge
on him and of course if venom gave Eddie
Brock that little tiny push of anger
that he needed he would certainly try to
seek revenge on spider-man
so that's Theory number one on to theory
number two theory number two comes from
Martin Hosea he is a theory on what
Captain America did when he went back in
time and the Fantastic Four
so when Captain America goes back in
time sometime during the 1970s he will
meet Howard Stark Captain America will
tell Howard Stark about captain and Tony
going back in time to try and save the
universe captain realizes that the world
was going to need more heroes so he
teams up with Howard and the two of them
tracked down the Fantastic Four the two
of them eventually find them and ask
them if they can give them a task to
come back in the future and defend the
earth mr. fantastic accepts the mission
for his team and they show up somewhere
in the future during the Falcon and
Winter Soldier series the Fantastic Four
helped Falcon and the Winter Soldier
defeat a major threat and at the end
Falcon asked them how they knew to
appear and mr. fantastic replies a man
from the 70s told us that we are running
out of heroes to defend the earth he
told us to come during this time so we
did when mr. fantastic tells him this
Falcon immediately realizes that it was
Steve that told him so there's a lot of
talk right now about a potential
Fantastic Four movie being in
development to enter the MCU in 2022 and
according to reports Peyton Reed who
directed ant-man and ant-man and the
wasp already has a script for a
Fantastic Four movie idea and that
script takes place in the 1960s so when
Captain America goes back in time and if
he meets Howard Stark in the 1970s the
Fantastic Four would be around and what
an awesome way it would be to bring back
Captain America in the MCU even for a
short amount of time to show what he did
back in time and to have him introduce
the Fantastic Four this would be a
really cool way to introduce them and to
have them appear in the Falcon in Winter
Soldier series there's a lot of cool
ways the Fantastic Four could be brought
into the MCU but I think that it would
be awesome to have capped
merica be a part of that so that does it
for theory number two on to number three
theory number three comes from you've
all a garv all and you've all steer e is
that after iron man sacrificed himself
to save everybody he became worthy to
wield Mjolnir
just like how Thor became unworthy in
the first Thor movie but then became
worthy again by sacrificing himself to
save his friends also the same way that
Captain America was worthy from the very
beginning by sacrificing himself to save
millions from hydras attack so Tony
Stark should be worthy as he sacrificed
himself to save the entire universe so
if Tony Stark's somehow returned in
theory he could wield Mjolnir this could
be something we could potentially see in
the what if Disney Plus series so I've
actually thought about this before - and
I think that Tony would be worthy and to
me it sort of has to do with what the
directors and the writers have said
about Tony story arc from the very
beginning in the beginning of the MCU he
was a very selfish person but by the end
and Avengers in game he was a self less
person and just like this theory states
Tony gave his life to save the entire
universe there's really no doubt in my
mind that that would make him worthy to
wield Mjolnir I definitely think that if
we see Tony Stark in a Disney plus
what-if story he could definitely
wheeled me linear so that's theory
number three on to number four theory
number four comes from Emily M who has a
theory about Marvel actors and Spider
Man far from home
Emily's theory is that Marvel tells the
actors and actresses to leak false
information or to accidentally spoil
something during an interview Emily says
that her reason is because a while back
after infinity war was released Tom
Holland said in an interview that Doctor
Strange had a lot of complicated lines
about the quantum realm but Doctor
Strange never had any lines about the
quantum realm and infinity wars so
everybody later assumed that Tom was
actually talking about endgame however
after Avengers in game came out Doctor
Strange still had no lines about the
quantum realm Emily says that the reason
she is using this example is because
recently Tom said that when Thanos
snapped his fingers he created the
elementals but I don't think that's true
I still think Mysterio created them
Emily thinks that Marvel told Tom to say
a lot of random stuff and to act like he
leaked things to throw fans off the same
way samuel l.jackson once said that
captain
could time travel he later then said he
made it up and was just blowing off
steam after work also if the actors and
actresses were to truly leak something
they would get in a lot of trouble so
Emily thinks that this proves that the
actors and actresses for marvel
intentionally leaked things and put out
fake spoilers I would definitely have to
agree with this I definitely think that
Marvel and the actors and actresses that
work with Marvel have a plan to put out
fake leaks and fake spoilers just to get
fans excited because it definitely works
it gets fans talking about the movie so
really why wouldn't they and I have to
agree with Emily i from the very
beginning thought that the elementals
were just illusions created by Mysterio
and even though I don't think they're
allusions anymore I definitely think
Mysterio did in fact create them the
suit that he wears looks like Chitauri
tech so he could have definitely made
the elementals out of jet re tech as
well so I definitely think that and
spider-man far from home we'll find out
that the elementals are a creation of
Mysterio slash Quentin Beck so that's
theory number four on to the final
Theory number five theory number five
comes from Andrew Molyneux Andrews
theory is also about Mysterio and
spider-man far from home and how he
thinks Mysterio is going to work
throughout the film he says that
throughout the trailers we keep hearing
Mysterio talking about his job and he
thinks that all of his equipment is from
his universe where he was the elementals
caretaker then when the snap happened
the elementals went through the
dimensional rift and Mysterio felt
obligated to follow them and hunt them
down and protect his new earth from them
it took five years to travel through the
rift then Mysterio shows up on our earth
and is legitimately trying to hunt them
down then Nick Fury brings in spider-man
and spider-man and Mysterio become best
friends
then after Mysterio and spider-man fight
off all of the elementals spider-man
gets all the credit and fame in turn
Mysterio gets very angry and then
spider-man and Mysterio go to the
dimensional rift throw the elementals in
but Mysterio doesn't go back he closes
the portal and stays behind Mysterio and
spider-man end up getting into an
argument and then they end up fighting
which leads to Peter ending up on the
ground all burned this is the scene that
we see him hugging MJ and when his suit
is all burned Mysterio doesn't kill him
because they were best friends but
Mysterio flies away and as he flies away
we hear him say something like if I
and get famed for being the hero maybe
I'll get famed for being the villain
this would fulfill the promise that
Marvel gave us that Mysterio story would
be similar to mortos from Doctor Strange
then at the end of the movie Peter feels
that he needs to reveal himself to the
world to fully step into iron man's role
pepper sets up the press conference and
the movie ends with Peter Parker saying
I am spider-man this is an interesting
take on Mysterio because we know
Mysterio is a villain but maybe they put
a little twist on it and start him off
as a good guy in having become the
villain by the end of the movie and this
would be just like more tough story from
Doctor Strange ultimately I do think
Mysterio will end up as a bad guy and I
think he will be in the sinister six in
spider-man 3 and Mysterio getting hurt
about the fame makes sense because in
the comics that's what Mysterio wants he
wants the fame he wants the love of
everybody so this is a theory that I
think we could see happen in spider-man
far from home so that does it for this
week's theories let's do a quick recap
theory number one is about venom being
introduced in spider-man 3 and into the
MCU theory number two is that at one
point we will see what Captain America
did back in time which was introduced
the Fantastic Four into the MCU theory
number three is that after Iron Man
sacrificed himself to save the entire
universe he is now worthy enough to lift
me own ear theory number four is that
the actors for Marvel Studios actually
intentionally leaked things on purpose
and theory number five is that Mysterio
is actually going to be a good guy but
when spider-man gets all the fame he
turns into a villain so those are this
week's theories be sure to vote on which
one you think is your favorite and again
if you would like to submit your own
theory for a chance to end up an episode
of Theory Thursdays you can find the
email to send it to and the instructions
in the description down below if you're
new to my channel be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on every
Theory Thursday and all Marvel related
content and as always thank you all so
much for watching
wolf wolf
[Music]